pendant 47 ans un homme un imposteur a
vécu sous l'identité d'un autre avant de
mourir un jour le véritable se voit
couper ses rentes normal pour sa caisse
de retraite c'est un amor
[Musique]
comment il a pu avoir mon identité
alors comment qu'il a pu la voir ou
surtout ou qu'il a eue
parce que la 46 47
je suis allé à paris
on m'a volé ma valise en arrivant à
montparnasse à l'eau et j'avais alors
que un niveau de 15 des parts dans la
valise moi je crois que cela est venue
de là c'est autrement je n'ai pas perdu
d'autres papiers demande bien utile ou
pas
[Musique]
ne voyons pas avoir marre en tout quinze
clubs 91
je suis allé voir ma manque le 30
octobre et elles n'étaient pas encore
versées à ses dettes
l'employé du guichet m'a dit d'aller
voir à la sécurité sociale puis ce matin
du 30 octobre
ma femme avait reçu une lettre de la
cram de nantes lui demandant de remplir
un imprimé ou la religion qu'elle a
droit sur cette lettre et en aviser de
10 msv ou georges moi même quand elle
m'a fait voir cet honnête je n'ai pas
perdu mon courage je suis allé le 31
octobre au matin au service de la
sécurité sociale danger c'est là que
j'ai découvert avec un employé après un
coup de téléphone à la cram dunlop que
j'étais bien décédé le 17 décembre 1989
à châteaubriant
c'est évident monsieur veron et vivent
bien vivant il habite angers où son
existence cool couler sans histoire
presque sans relief le mort c'est un
usurpateur un homonyme un autre georges
verront domicilié depuis une quarantaine
d'années à nantes dont la populaire rue
du maréchal joffre entre l'église simple
aimant et le regard bienveillant des
louis saez étonné d'avoir survécu à tant
de guerres et de révolutions
georges était domicilié là mais son
ancien propriétaire monsieur piqué
nelson pour les intimes qui le loge de
gratuitement en échange de petits
travaux nous a refusé son témoignage
comme monsieur toucheront le pâtissier
voisins
[Musique]
si vous avez une bagarre avec un kanak
par exemple dans un café ou un truc
comme ça faut jamais lui taper sur la
tête parce qu'il a une tête celle du
mouton faut lui taper dans les codes
comme ça ça l'est ça me coupe le souffle
les genres jeux verront jamais dans ces
coups là jamais en fin de ma
connaissance un même de la rue et c'est
un type qui vous voyez tous les jours
bonjour salut avant des services faire
un peu de béton un crochet attaché et
puis on buvait une shopping comme ça il
était client un peu chez moi mais un
type sans histoire jamais on aurait
pensé que je pense qu'il avait fait
qu'il avait un passé
il parlait pas de sa vie on buvait un
verre comme ça il fait le bourbon mais
jamais rien n'est même pas de son
travail parce que quand on a vu dans la
presse qu'il avait été chez un docteur à
tout ça je pense pas qu'il y ait de
grandes grand monde qu'il ne savait la
voyez donc c'était s'était caché quoi
moi je pense qu'il y avait fait une
croix sur quelque chose quoi le docteur
olliéric et madame n'ont pas voulu non
plus de nous parler de georges verront
leurs valets de chambre très stylé
paraît-il au début des années 50
[Musique]
georges verront travaillait le jardin de
madame morin madame morin rémunéré
georges verrons avec des légumes elle
assista aux obsèques de son jardinier
mais garde un silence obstiné
[Musique]
depuis 32 ans que je suis ici j'ai bien
connu monsieur verrons qui était un
client habituel
il venait le samedi en principe vers
12h30 pour chercher ses produits
d'entretien ses produits de toilette et
autrement ils me prenaient du gaz teddy
les thèmes fort aimable quand il
rentrait il me disait toujours bonjour
madame
j'ai bien l'honneur de vous saluer et en
même temps il me faisait le baisemain il
était très réservé il ne racontait pas
ses affaires sa vie intime je la
connaissais pas mon mari peut-être la
connaissez peut-être davantage mais
malheureusement il est décédé depuis
longtemps alors je ne sais pas très bien
ce qui lui a raconté quoi bien sûr c'est
un garçon vraiment bien et d'une
instruction potable je pense même qu'il
serait lui-même touché le secondaire
déjà à cette époque là je me rappelle
que verront georges était toujours vêtue
simplement mais toujours proche il avait
surtout été connu habillé avec un trois
quarts qui n'étaient pas en cuir mais
qui était en plexi pente genre de
commandes audio de plexi la de noir et
puis là c'est le garçon quand vous
l'invitez ne s'imposait pas il était
assez mais on peut même dire assez
timide
si l'arrivée dans une assemblée avec des
amis c 'est pas il ne s'asseyait pas si
on le priait pas de le faire
c'est un garçon je pense qu'ils étaient
assez assez assez effacé à s'effacer
et puis par la suite je les revues aussi
avec une paire de bottes noires mais je
pense que ce garçon là aurait pu soit
s'occuper d'un haras ou peut-être passer
son régiment comme ils disaient qu'ils
avaient été en afrique
alors donc cette habitude lda cette
habitude la lui était peut-être rester
je crois que ce garçon là
certainement quelque chose à cacher
parce que ils n'essayaient pas se lier
rien du tout mais je n'ai même jamais pu
savoir vraiment d'ailleurs je ne
l'interrogé pas pour savoir ce qu'il
avait fait dans sa jeunesse que ce qui
était devenu ansériens vie de celui et
en quelques années plus vieux que moi je
pense qu'il est appartenu à des
formations peut-être politique peut-être
politique ou alors à cette époque là
c'était la guerre il y en a qui ont sans
verser dans la résistance d'autres ont
passé ont viré de l'autre côté duquel
côté qu'il était ce qu'il avait quelque
chose vraiment à se cacher ça vraiment
je ne peux rien vous dire je n'en sais
rien du tout mais certainement
certainement que mais moi je ne le
critique pas si vraiment ils avaient ils
seuls à se faire oublier comme ça s'il
avait rien fait d'extraordinaire il
avait raison et je crois qu'il a dû et
peut-être bien un esprit un petit peu sa
faute comme ça en restant seul seuls
soldes seules ne voulant pas ça à voir
d'amitié ou deux
copains quand j'ai connu cela se verront
j'avais environ 15 ans il travaille son
père thomas son modèle j'étais apprenti
et s'est créée entre nous des liens
d'amitié il avons conservé une amitié
entre nous jusqu'à sa mort moi j'ai
connu jean perron un tout petit peu plus
tard à celui de mon mariage j'ai trouvé
cet homme très cultivé très gentil à
tout point de vue on avait les aider
à tout niveau à comparer des liens
d'amitié même nom sorti onze avions
beaucoup de choses en commun
oui pour nous georges à mon avis était
un homme très diplomate pour nous en
plus instruits avec qui on aimait bien
parler d'une bonne intelligence
on aimait bien dialogué ensemble on
faisait pas mal de choses en commun
ne serait-ce que même jouer aux dames
donc sa culture était quand même quelque
chose de bien recommandable j'ai rien à
dire là dessus à plusieurs fois elle
s'était confiée à plusieurs reprises il
s'était confié à moi sur sa vie passée à
veiller de raconter donc sa vie
militaire à l'âge de 18 ans dans les
bataillons d'afrique engagé ensuite je
sais qu'il avait fait partie des croix
de feu avant la guerre de 39 45
je sais aussi que il avait fait un
cambriolage à paris il avait cambriolé
un magasin de fourrures qu'il avait pris
une petite peine
je crois que même s'ils s'étaient évadés
c'est d'ailleurs là que je pense que il
avait réussi dans la guerre de paris
dont par l'a7 entre autres je pense à
récupérer des payes de montparnasse ou
angers je me souviens plus très bien
parce que j'ai pas pris des notes à
cette époque qu'il avait réussi à
prendre des papiers du vrai du vrai
georges v oui moi je sais qu'il n'y met
pas du tout les arabes mais
tout ce qui était maghrébin mais il n'a
jamais fait quoique équivoque il n'a
jamais bousculé personne au contraire il
se faisait très discret ce niveau-là il
préférait partir plutôt que de les voir
et on sentait franchement qu'il avait
souffert à ce niveau là sauf certains
chantiers chez mon père avait quitté le
chantier s'il y avait des arabes à
travailler ça c'est une évidence mais il
n'a jamais il n'aurait jamais fait de
mal à une mouche nous l'été lui j'ai un
très très bon souvenir au niveau de mes
enfants surtout les n'est pas ce qu'il a
fait participation de mon accouchement
est avec moi et surtout avec eux il a
toujours toujours été bon toujours il
avait des petits cadeaux il était
attentif à ce niveau là pour leur
anniversaire pour l'heure fait c'était
quelque chose de super avec lui aussi
georges revenait aujourd'hui il
conserverait toute ma sympathie et mon
amitié est quelqu'un d'exceptionnel
[Musique]
des souvenirs flous des ruines d'anciens
lieux de travail où le fantôme du faux
verront doit ricaner devant notre
curiosité
peu de choses chronologie difficile
impossible portrait la silhouette de
georges verront l'imposteur s'enfuit
dans les mémoires paresseuse dans les
craintes peut être justifié
là où seul l'imaginaire pourrait
rétablir des faits improbable
[Musique]
e
ce
je n'en veux pas à l'homme qui repose là
tout ce que je demande au tribunal quand
je voyais pas c'est qu'on enlève la
plaque de mon nom de toute sa tombe
messi veron et qui nous assure que c'est
vous les vrais veron et pas les
messieurs qui répondent ici c'est moi
même de georges verront n'est langer 24
9 218 et c'est bien moins les deux vu
avec mes papiers de la mairie d'angers
mais j'ai dit j'ai quand même les
preuves que c'est loin mais l'autre au
chili et l'autre je crois que c'est un
faux verrous mais ils avaient les
papiers les yoshis win avait des papiers
alors il avait pour tous les papiers
qu'il fallait il y en avait un qui nie
la papier qu'ils n'en avaient pas dans
le vrai c'est vous c'est moi
grosse bagarre
[Musique]